parisians and residents of eight other
badly affected cities have been under
curfew since saturday
but that hasn't stopped them from taking
to the streets in discontent
in paris a crowd of people marched
against the new measures these include
getting special permission to go out
between 9pm and 6am
the government insisting a curfew is the
only way to avoid
another strict lockdown restaurant and
bar owners are particularly unhappy
since they're forced to shutter during
their most profitable hours
to ensure the rules are respected the
french president outlined several
punishments for violators
the first time will bring a fine of over
100 euros and it only gets steeper from
there
repeat offenders could pay 3 000 euros
and even find themselves behind bars for
six
months charlotte dubensky has been
finding out how the hospitality sector
is going to survive
between nine pm and six am every night
for possibly up to six weeks
no one is allowed outside without an
authorisation or a medical emergency
for restaurants already struggling to
cope there is concern that these new
measures
will make times even leaner
if everybody needs to be at home at nine
it means we have to
close or serve the last dish at eight
the time to clean the time to go home
means a service between
seven and eight which is not not
parisian at all
and i'm not sure we will have enough
clients and
he's worried this could mean many
restaurants are hung out to dry
it becomes cynical we get we're getting
used to it
and so we try to do our best but uh it's
uh
an enormous number of restaurants and
i'm not gonna survive it but
don't survive as we speak so
yeah it's a big big nail in the coffin
bar and restaurant unions have also
warned that the impact
could be dire now they previously
outlined how 15
of cafes bars and restaurants face
potential bankruptcy
with a quarter of a million staff facing
unemployment in france
it is clear that this decision is
equivalent to a reclosing of our
establishments
and has serious consequences for the
hotel cafe and catering sector
already hard hit by the crisis we
qualify these measures as punitive
against the hotel and catering sector
their aim is to dissuade a minority of
people who do not respect
basic health precautions and will have
dramatic consequences
on the profession while the government
has
announced more help for the sector many
owners of eating establishments have
said
this aid is for their workforce not them
and that they've essentially been left
without a wage
the curfew has been brought in though in
the latest attempt by the french
government
to bring down the number of kovid 19
positive tests
even president macron has expressed
concern about the rising numbers of
cases
that need hospital attention including
those who need to go
into intensive care
our emergency rooms and our hospitals
are in a more
worrying situation than in march because
we don't have a reserve of beds
which is why we have to take measures
that are more strict
while polls suggest the majority of
people do support the curfew there are
those who are vocally opposing it
including the mayor of marseille who's
adopter
by profession how can you not be angry
when this measure targets the wrong
things and fails to address the root
cause
whatever else we do we need to support
our hospitals whose abandonment for
years is deplorable
with around 20 million people now
obliged to stay
inside at night many are still left
wondering
if this measure is enough to fight the
virus
as the battle against covid limps on
you